where do you think this level of anger
is coming from because it appears to me
that that's what's new like these
political divides have always existed
these political divides between right
and left
or political divides between people who
are more interested in collective
solutions versus individual solutions
why do you think people are so pissed
all the time i mean they're just
you can feel it in the air like the the
eagerness to stomp on somebody's face
is really strong that's why when the
roseanne thing happens it can't just be
like what you're saying
where okay she's a mentally ill person
maybe you have to take the show off the
air maybe that's the proper response
but she might actually have a problem
here she ha
she certainly does um what i think it's
coming from is toxic tribalism that's
what i think
i think people uh they're on a team they
want their team to win
and they want their team to win by any
means necessary and they're
they feel disenfranchised because we
have a president
uh you know donald trump i mean he is
who he is and
he stands for a lot of things that they
find abhorrent
and you you have a lot of people now
that are calling themselves antifa
and they're they're by literally by
their own actions
acting in a fascist manner and they're
calling themselves anti-fascists
and they're putting bandanas in their
face they're hitting people with bike
locks and
they're engaged in violence and the the
left is using
violence as a means to solve these
differences that we have and ideas and
opinions
they're shutting people down like
christina hoff summers just yelling out
at her
a woman who's her whole life has been a
feminist
her whole life and she calls herself a
factual feminist because she wants
women who are empowered and who are
intelligent to be held accountable for
their
the actual facts behind what they're
saying and
you know to to discuss this to empower
people with reality
and by doing that she's become an enemy
i mean it's very strange to watch her
get shouted down by
other feminists that think that she's
the wrong kind of feminist
it's it's really bizarre but
the anger in the the vitriol and the the
the violence that's attached to it is
something that's completely new
and was always associated with
right-wing thuggish mobs
it was always associated with hate
groups like the kkk
or or some something along those lines
you know
neo-nazis but you're seeing this level
of violence
from from the left now these weird
like university professors and these
dorky people that are saying burn this
down and and people are
cheering the streets and
white people are the problem and and
there's so many people that are tenured
professors
that are getting away with saying like
ridiculous crazy
and calling out for violence and it's
completely irresponsible
and it's it's it's foolish it feels
weird too because you know back in the
1960s at least there was something to
fight over
right at least back in the 1960s if you
were gay you said okay i don't have my
rights
there's something to fight over or
you're black you say i don't have my
rights true
there's something to fight over or
you're female and you say well feminism
hasn't hasn't done what it needs to do
yet there's something to fight for but
right now country's pretty good
like things are pretty good for the vast
majority of people in this country put
aside the economics for a second because
people always fail a rise in economics
it just happens
but and some of that is natural and some
of that is stuff that's fixable but
one thing that is certainly true is that
the notion of a governmental invasion of
rights against any of these groups
this is not something that is commonly
happening it's not that the government
is cracking down on black people or
hispanic people
or at this point even gay people and yet
there's this level of anger that feels
like
riots in the 1960s we're talking about
sort of the levels of chaos and
i have a theory so my laid out for you
so my theory and i don't know where you
stand religiously
are you agnostic atheist religious more
agnostic than anything
i grew up catholic and i abandoned it
when uh i was a young boy i went to
catholic school
and that cured me so here's my theory my
theory is that
everybody has broken down into tribalism
because it used to be that we were a
larger tribe
meaning that the way that you the way
that you defeat local tribalism is
by creating a larger tribe that
everybody feels a kinship to and a
membership to so in the united states
you had people who've had tribal
kinship to state government and then
after the civil war that basically went
away
because the federal government stepped
in and stopped slavery through
through war making power and then people
felt a general kinship to the federal
government you were american now it
wasn't that you were californian or you
were texan
you were now american uh and the same
thing goes back to biblical times where
you have
you know all of these various tribes you
have tribe of manasseh and the tribe of
and the tribe of ephraim and all but
they're they're the jews right
there's a bigger tribe that eats them uh
and it used to be the tribe
for america was called america right and
that tribe was was bonded by a certain
set of creedal values values of
individual rights
values of personal virtue that these
things had to be combined you had to be
a good person to your neighbors
but at the same time the government had
no right to to come in and take your
stuff
and force you to be a nicer person so
you were the idea was that
you voluntarily were going to be a nicer
person to your neighbors because you
thought that was the right thing to do
but it wasn't the government's job to
come in and force you to be nicer to
your neighbors because that would be
fascistic and overbearing and tyrannical
and that's gone away because people
don't feel like they have to be nice to
their neighbors they
and i think part of that has to be
connected with lack of communal
institutions
that you know i'm not saying everybody
has to go to church but people who are
in churches tend to get along better
with each other in the church
than people who are outside the church
and people inside the church doesn't
mean that you got to pick a church
but it doesn't mean that we have to have
some sort of communal institutions and
right now we are savagely tearing apart
each of our communal institutions
up to and including things like the nfl
where suddenly things were
we would bond over that like super bowl
sunday was a bonding time for the
country
and now we can't even bond over that we
can't bond over anything right now
because all of these creedal values have
been
dissipated by our own personal
malevolence toward each other
i think that's a great point i think
it's a great point too about the benefit
of religion
is that you do have these ideas and
values that are shared amongst this
community and group and
when you are an atheist or an agnostic i
mean you don't really have that group
other than like what you're what you're
getting from a lot of atheists you get
this really
hardcore progressive ideology that is in
many ways like a religion and
i i think there's there's probably some
real merit to what you're saying
and robert putnam makes this point in uh
in his book bowling alone he talks about
this this new fascination with diversity
and the diversity is our strength and
this this whole line
and he was a big believer in this robert
putnam this professor of sociology is
big lefty and and he says that that
diversity was our strength was his
guiding kind of
notion and then he did the research into
it what he found is that as diversity of
a census tract increases the only thing
that he found that increased our protest
marches and tv watching
that's the only thing that actually
increases in a particular area based on
ethnic diversity
he said the only area where he could see
that ethnic diversity actually made
things better
was in the context of a broader group so
in the army for example then ethnic
diversity is great because then you get
a bunch of people who are fighting for
the same purpose and the guy next to
your brother doesn't matter if he's
black or white you see this with
people who you talk to who are in the
military all the time when they talk
about people of different races in the
military
this is usually the way they talk about
people of different races in the
military which is very
different than the way people talk about
race in the united states where bradley
said you also see this in churches
but communal institutions have have
declined so markedly
that the only way i think that we're
going to be able to have a system where
we can all live with each other is to
re-establish some sort of
some form of communal talking with each
other even if it's just forums like this
one
uh where we're talking with each other
and you know we if we did this live we'd
get thousands of people to show up just
to hear us talk to each other
even those sort of communal institutions
need to exist otherwise we're going to
completely polarize i mean i think it's
one of the dangers of the
i love the internet i've made my living
on the internet you make your living on
the internet but one of the dangers of
the internet
is that it's all personal to you you
don't actually have to go out and be
with other human beings you get to hide
behind the screen and tweet nasty things
at each other
yeah you also can find this group of
like-minded people and you share an echo
chamber that's that's another
real issue for confirmation bias i think
what you're saying makes a lot of sense
and
i think that we do need we do need
community
you know and i think the more people
like you and like sam harris and
eric and brett weinstein people who are
open-minded people who are willing to
discuss things politely with people and
not shove their ideology down other
people's throats
the more we exchange information with
each other the more this idea of being
able to communicate like this
becomes popular and i think there's real
benefit in that i think there's real
benefit
in these kind of podcast style
discussions because of that
because you can sit down with with a
person that maybe doesn't share the same
opinions with you and you can talk
things out and
maybe disagree maybe argue but be polite
to each other
and realize that a lot of these ideas
that we have
we we have these predetermined notions
of the way we think
things should be and if you don't fit
with my predetermined notions
then there's must be something wrong
with you it's never just
examining these notions and finding out
where these ideas coming from and why am
i so married to them
and what what is the solution to make
everybody comfortable is there a
solution can and can we stop demonizing
people that disagree with us